well hello everyone thank you so much
David for being here I want to introduce
David Wallerstein who is the chief
exploration officer at $0.10 David
joined $0.10 in 2000 when the company
had only 45 employees and today you have
about 38,000 I believe so
I'll have to check with our head of HR
give or take a few thousand here and
there well it is clearly one of the
world's largest internet companies as
well as the largest gaming company in
the world and as many of you know $0.10
is also the creator of V chat so thank
you David for joining us today and also
for speaking at our private event I do I
seen anything thank you
so let's go back to even three mm you
know you grew up in the u.s. what took
you to China that's a very long answer
I'm going to try to make it short but it
kind of relates to my work today I was
always pretty deeply concerned about the
world and trends in the world and I felt
that going back to I guess the early
1990s as a student studying global
trends in studying global history I felt
China was destined to become a very
important country that the economy was
going to continue to grow it had been
growing in the early 90s but China was
not a popular country for at least
Americans back there at least myself the
way I viewed the world it was kind of
like on the side and other countries
like Japan were a much bigger deal I
actually had spent time living in Japan
you went to high school in high school
there I was an exchange student I had
lived with a Japanese family and yeah I
was a Japanese person basically for the
time I lived there I've lived in Japan
on and off for about four years and that
made me very comfortable just speaking a
foreign language in the Asian language
and being the only non Asian in the room
has always seemed very natural to me
even since before I was 16 but then when
I got interested in China I kind of
redeployed this skill set that I had
developed to kind of survive in Japan as
a kid which is like you just have to
learn the language super fast so went
from Japan to China how you know and I
know you also talked about NASPA
sort of exploring in fact potentially
acquiring $0.10 yes you know plead 2001
talk about how did you first come across
okay yeah so I was doing management
consulting in China so take that all
that background I told you about and I
ended up having a passion for getting
foreign companies into China again oh
the theme I was talking about the
China's gonna be very important for the
rest of the world I was thinking the the
theme in my mind really from the mid-90s
was how do we help China integrate to
the rest of world
so China is a productive member all the
great international institutions out
there work for China as they do America
and the other countries in China is just
part of our global community right in a
very proactive way yeah and I thought
the best way to do that would be to
integrate the Chinese economy with the
rest of the world and to accelerate that
so I was very interested in the 90s to
bring US companies to China I was
working as a management consultant
predominantly for like
telecommunications and what we called IT
related issues back that was
pre-internet yeah right and and then I
started helping these different
companies and in 1999 very early I think
was February 1989 I came across a
company called Naspers who became my
client I was very young at the time like
20-something 21 maybe and they wanted to
enter China's internet market and they
had recently done a Nasdaq listing and
had quite a bit of capital to back their
plans maybe it was like a hundred
million dollars or something which was a
lot of money back then and still a lot
of money today right so yeah so we
started working together to invest in
different companies in China social
networking companies we didn't call him
that they were like dating sites back
then or chat sites or blogging sites
although that wasn't a word either
posting sites I was very fascinated by
these kinds of websites because they
created a lot of traffic and the users
seemed to want to spend a lot of time
there and that made a lot of sense it
may be more like yeah who's about yeah
pageviews and I was always interested to
find engagement like deep user
engagement but something happened when I
was doing this kind of M&A that
investment type work work for Naspers in
China and that's that I noticed all the
entrepreneurs
tended to use this tool called oh I CQ
at the time and often they wouldn't
include any method to contact them like
email or phone other than this tool and
one day it kind of hit me saying wait a
second
this seems really important I was
totally overlooking it I was looking for
websites basically and instead I could
see that like the whole Chinese internet
seemed to be kind of connected or
somehow like structured by everyone's
use of this tool we later changed our
name to QQ in the year 2001 yeah in the
year 2000 I had this idea that I should
go down to Shenzhen which seemed a
little far for us foreign type people
back then we were pretty much yeah all
living in Beijing and Shanghai and
that's kind of like where the hipsters
used to all aggragate Beijing Shanghai
and we're having a great life there
partying at night and stuff like that
feeling really good about ourselves and
and we didn't really tend to get out of
those cities very often so I remember
kind of feeling proud of myself getting
on a plane to go see Ponemah mm-hmm maha
tong our co-founder and and there's a
team of four about five co-founders that
were started $0.10 and running the
company as the executive team at the
time I went down to Shenzhen to go visit
them and that's where the whole
relationship with $0.10 started
he's middle of June 2002 and 2010 there
to to propose to $0.10 that we should
try to acquire them and what was their
response yeah well I had a lot of
different kinds of meetings over the
years you're trying to do being a
consultant
it was pretty accustomed to having those
meetings go well generally people were
happy to see me and wanted to find a way
to work together
I think the Tencent folks pretty
politely told me that it wasn't gonna
work out thank you for coming and
goodbye
yeah and I was kind of shocked I'd never
really had that experience quite in that
way before but in the meetings it was
clear to me that these were some of the
smartest people I had ever met in my
life
Chinese American whatever I was just
completely blown away by how strategic
they were thinking about their business
how how realistic they were having this
discussion with me and I I didn't want
to just have the meeting end on a sour
note so
you didn't give up right you actually
ended up like Naspers left the
investment in $0.10 a year or two later
we did later that's that's the that's
where things ended up but but it started
off pretty difficult ultimately I felt
like we had to demonstrate that we could
bring some unique value so I started um
well first of all I invited everyone to
dinner and we proceeded to get I recall
things we got pretty drunk that night I
do not recommend this for the children
at home but it did happen and and then
the next morning I went back to the
company just to see if there's anything
we could do together
and I remember bringing in some ideas
from the u.s. from the foreign market
that that seemed actually pretty
interesting
Tony and the other guys and and I said
that's it I think the way to actually
have a relationship here is to see what
kind of value we could bring to $0.10
from the outside world and and how could
we help $0.10 with expansion even from
those early days like mid 2000 it was
pretty clear that was going to be the
basis of a viable relationship
ultimately it took about a year to buy
effectively half of 10 cent as Naspers
and and really the day after we signed
the deal I did a few things but the most
important one was I said I'm moving to
the US next we're gonna leave you guys
alone entirely and this wasn't just only
my idea up to the the top of Naspers
everyone very much supported this kind
of structure where okay we may have a
meaningful share in the company but to
make this thing work we absolutely have
to never do anything to bother this
company and be good shareholders and
really get out of the way and so to make
that very clear I moved to the US really
immediately and at the same time I said
I'll be back in two weeks and I did that
for until maybe a couple years ago I was
going back and forth between the US and
China and they every three weeks or so
when did you become an employer yeah
that was June of 2001 like really as
soon as we signed the deal okay
even before we sign the deal I was
spending a lot of time with the company
and we were we were working together on
different ideas to to build the company
it was kind of like as if like I know
this deal is gonna happen let's not
worry about these papers and documents
yeah all this frustrating legal
stuff let's just get to work yeah
meanwhile we're sitting around here
let's build the company and therefore
was very clear what the relationship
would be like after the deal closed
because they know what it's like to work
with me and then the other person who
worked with me on the deal is Charles
Searle he went on the board of Tencent
we're still here to this day so here we
are you know we started the deal
together 17 years ago we're still doing
it today Charles is on the board I'm
still on the executive team and there's
been this really wonderful continuity
between Naspers and Tencent where the
principles that I just described you
have remained true all of this time and
I think that's a great guideline in
general for complex shareholder
relationships by the way for this may
not be exactly the thing for the YC
crowd right now but it's it's a model
that could come up later for founder's
you don't necessarily just have to go
public or get acquired there's this
other model where you could potentially
sell a big chunk of your equity to a
third party and have this more nuanced
relationship which could actually be an
interesting outcome because you could
sell a lot of shares but still retain a
lot of shares and you can even ask for
more shares over time like more options
and things like that it's not unheard of
but but we actually find the model team
works really well with the red team's
and we always thought this was would be
a very common model in business and it
turned out that there aren't so many of
these types of deals being done yeah
it's a very unique model yeah I matter
in fact like not a lot of investments
what they even did this day in the US
especially with companies I would love
to do more of them but it's hard to find
that team that is willing to do it and
it's helpful if the Cummings profitable
because then you know how to value the
company going forward based on profits
versus like just only user growth yeah
other metric so you know it works better
with profitable yeah that means but yes
let's talk about that a little so you
joined the company when in 2001 yeah
pretty much when they had only 45
employees or maybe just QQ yeah today 10
cent to the outside world feels like
they do a lot of things they are also
known as the biggest gaming company they
also and have V chat probably one of the
best messengers of any team team but
it's an important one thing yeah so talk
about you know it's it's broad from 2000
to 2017 is almost like you know I'm
talking about 17 years but yeah how did
you what you know
but how did Tencent decide to evolve
from QQ to all these other products and
what sort of motivated the
decision-making demoting serious so it's
a great question I hope I can do justice
to it how do you cover you know 17 years
in a few minutes right there are a few
important things to understand about
$0.10 that inform the product strategy
so when I first met the company in 2000
we had a couple key things going for us
one was pretty much most all of the
Chinese internet was inside QQ so the
strategic question for the company and
us as investors myself you know getting
involved would be like okay we seem to
have pretty close to a hundred percent
market penetration can we maintain that
going forward what could possibly make
that go wrong but we were starting kind
of with the wind at our backs and I
think that situation was true roughly
from early 2000 the company by the way
QQ started in February 1999 and thank
you just for the audience is it just
like we started as a pc-based instant
messaging service so I think of it I
know the media products too big of a
deal of this because they always think
Chinese companies copy everything but
they'll say it's the Chinese version of
ICQ or a.i.m or MSN Messenger yahoo
messenger so yahoo messenger is the
Yahoo version of ICQ I guess you know
but it was the I am client got it still
has a lot of users today yeah and so
that was really usually for a Chinese
user back then when they would get on
the internet they'd start their session
with QQ and often they were logging in
via an internet cafe a shared PC mm-hm
and then you know at the end of their
session doing their stuff in the the
internet cafe they would log off QQ so
our average usage times the second
factor first was like having this
ability in the market like almost
everyone using it the second thing was
the users to attend the scene about four
hours a day so it offers a day yeah like
like an average aggregated time tell
users yeah it's a long time yeah and and
so we started thinking okay things can
go wrong but so far they're going really
well yeah almost all users are in here
four hours a day so how do we build the
day because they're chatting with
someone else yeah they're they're kind
of there they're logged in and QQ is
actually it did two things it did
instant messaging and it did something
called presence and presence was
basically just a way to indicate by
lighting up your avatar if that you were
online so if you're offline your your
avatar me black and white if you're
online it would be in color and that was
very valuable back then because people
would want to talk to each other and be
in touch with each other in real time
and you want to know is someone there or
not mmm and then you can start adding
subfields to presents like you could add
a little like a tweet yeah like I said
today I'm really happy today
got it or here I just did this whatever
you know like it's it's kind of like the
precursor to Twitter and all the guys
I've bundled in with your messaging
mm-hmm all nicely packaged in this app
okay
so that's how I started so we we face
this question we've got a great
situation going how do we continue what
could get in the way and we felt pretty
early on the answers like well we have
to keep innovating and we have to really
deeply understand our users and what
they need to anticipate the next thing
that they want now we did find something
that worked really well in the early
days from early 2001 we started doing
mobile instant messaging what we call
mobile QQ mm-hmm and this is really how
we went public on the Nasdaq in 2004 was
on the back of this mobile service which
connected the PC based QQ application to
your mobile phone so you could send a
message between your PC to a mobile user
and back and forth to enable that
service on your mobile phone a mobile
phone user would have to pay us five RMB
mm-hmm a month about 60 cents so if you
didn't want it then who cares you don't
have it but if you wanted to be able to
on the go with your SMS back so there's
all feature phones with smart phones if
you wanted to be able to text back and
forth to QQ you'll pay us five RMB a
month and there are so many users on QQ
and this feature became sufficiently
demanded that it really drove our
financial performance right up to the
IPO in 2004 so based on this it's
important for everyone to know that we
became profitable as a company in June
2001 and we've never had not been
profitable since so this is pretty much
the time when Naspers closed the deal
they were closing a deal on a company
that's profitable cash flow positive
based on rolling out these mobile QQ
services across the country and we would
bring the service to maybe Guangdong and
even have nice growth then we bring it
to like another problems like
and we're saying okay what's gonna
happen at Hunan and the next day it's
like you know get a big explosion of
users and it's like great now the
revenues coming in and then it became
really a battle in the first few years
2001 2002 to make sure we had your big
with his presence across all of the
mobile networks in China China Mobile
China Unicom so on and so forth and each
deal would drive more cash for the
company because the the users were there
yeah so we had cash we had profitability
we had this engagement with users we had
the four hours roughly ss- on average in
logged in to QQ so and I don't think I
fully answer your question people would
do other things on the internet they
would just always have QQ logged in in
the background and then they might go in
and start having multiple chats with
different people sharing information
whatever they've got to do but then they
might also do other things on the
internet but QQ is just kind of always
on the desktop somewhere so we felt like
we had this latent opportunity so we
started to do more experimentation to to
drive products for our users both for
user value perspectives and also like we
had to make money because okay something
to clarify very different than the US
market here is that the ad market from
our perspective has always been pretty
challenging in China compared to the US
and particularly for us we found our
users did not like ads in their
messaging experience so they would go
through great links to develop software
and these kind of hacks so they wouldn't
have to see the ads and the song felt
like that was kind of endangering the
user experience so we did always have an
ad team and we're getting much better at
and we have different types of inventory
today but the ads in the messaging
window was never really a viable option
for us unlike our friends it may be like
Google or other companies you know then
Facebook yeah they just driven these
massive businesses so how do you
monetize that alright so I want to make
that clear because $0.10 historically
like the rule of thumb things are
changing over time we've traditionally
made 90 percent of our revenues that's
like the rule of thumb historically in
my mind from our users paying directly
for our services and we call them
value-added services and then the 10%
would be like add related revenues and
right so starting with the mobile QQ
service the five rmb a month God so you
know there will have very you know
fully strong dedicated product teams
thinking about nothing other than how
can I get users to convert to mobile QQ
what more value can I add and these are
subscription services so you have to
keep your turn rate very low so you
really have to understand why someone
values it and then what might cause them
to leave and then we have to build all
these features around the service to
discourage someone from ever wanting to
leave it we want to have them forever
that was the first major value added
service of 10 cent and we launched
something around the same time which
also grew pretty significantly we kind
of like our number two big service which
we call premium cute so I was always
kind of dumbfounded that we didn't
really see many US companies build at
least our peers in social network you
build like a premium version of our
service especially when it's been so
successful and so important to our
product strategy premium Kiku is kind of
like how it sounds just a better version
of QQ we have to put more types of
value-added services in there and in the
early days I remember a key aspect of
premium QQ was you could choose your own
QQ number mm-hmm what does this mean ok
so have to explain these things yeah
it's a different market right the QQ
number before was your identifier it
wasn't like David at $0.10 com that we
didn't use email identifier as we used
an actual number and we did that because
we wanted to have the numbering system
of QQ work with the telecom network got
it we'd never really pushed that far in
that direction but we thought maybe the
QP number is your telecom number or the
future and it'll just map really nicely
what the switches and yeah I know we did
different things around that it never
really took off but that was like the
thinking like numbers are better than
names gods you can just punch it into a
keypad so you could choose your own and
in China numbers are very important for
example some of the people watching may
not know 8 is a very lucky number in
China so if you're gonna deal with China
remember that it's lucky if you got some
eights in your phone it's a good thing
to have yeah a phone number or whatever
it means ha yeah to get rich I think you
know like prosperity so if you're a a
user and you want to kind of stand out
from the crowd I mean what young person
doesn't want to have a little edge out
there right
get some eights in your number and then
maybe when you show up in the chat room
your name shows up in a different color
like a red color and you kind of quickly
establish yourself as a bit
High Roller mm-hmm and you've you kind
of emerge from the crowd so the other
thing I need to tell you is there was a
lot of dating going on in QQ back in the
day I don't know what happens in there
today it's true for most in the US I
mean I think when Yahoo Messenger and
you know other instant messages that
launched I mean there were rooms that
were really dedicated chat room is
dedicated for ladies yeah I'll
definitely say that was probably part of
the experience yeah
not that I would know personally of
course but I just heard from a friend of
a friend of a friend that that's the
case so if you can kind of get an edge
in such an environment by having a
premium service that gives you you know
more status maybe but in a fair way and
then more like kind of functionality
maybe we'd give you more storage space
I know storage kind of like became less
of a big deal with Gmail and all those
later on but we would continuously be
building out our premium services
package to make it like the ultimate
thing to reduce churn and we'd have very
dedicated teams very committed to just
thinking nothing about nothing other
than the premium service package every
day of the year which drove all to the
monetization withdraw organization yeah
so these were kind of like I'd say
really two of the key pillars of our
monetization leading up to the IPO but
we had to diversify so now I'm going to
get into like the whole diversification
disk because we felt as a pure i.m
company doing mobile instant messaging
on one side that's like kind of you have
like PC in here then you got like mobile
kind of sticking off here and then like
this premium top of the pyramid here
like service and maybe both are only
getting 10% of your users so of a
hundred percent you only get 10% paying
we felt like as a company we could just
get taken out overnight by like we
mentioned Yahoo Messenger MSN Messenger
a AOL ICQ in fact we were particularly
concerned about Microsoft I think no
discussion of $0.10 history is complete
without a serious discussion about
Microsoft because around this time 2001
2002 I believe Microsoft did something
very important for us they bundled
Windows Messenger into the operating
system so you would get your Windows PC
and all of a sudden you got Windows
Messenger just popping up and we thought
this is absolutely going to kill us and
they were there I know they're a
competitive company today
back then they really scared the hell
out of us excuse me it was it was scary
time so we
figured what can we do to be competitive
against this kind of you know such a
powerful like no resources or a limit
type company like Microsoft we really
did two things
we went very local and we started
building more via two services so let me
talk about the local part we said you
know our products may change over time
this really informed our strategy is the
kind of customer engagement and product
we said we as our core value we
absolutely need to know our users better
than anyone else in the world we have to
at the most fundamental level know like
everything we can about them in terms of
their product preferences what they what
kind of features they like and don't
like what kind of colors they like and
don't like and how do you do that I know
Tencent especially star is very unique
there are really understanding the value
of the customer versus just looking at
metrics in fact you going the term see
customer engagement is yes so can you
talk a little more about how what
methods do you use to really understand
the cutting into that and then you have
to remind me to do then yes yeah I think
it's something that's really about the
people who run ten cent in the culture
of the company and it really goes to why
caring about users really goes to why
why we exist yeah and you know
ultimately every business is established
for some reasons it's often not apparent
to the employee sometimes or the user
sometimes because you say this company
just as X and I love X but you don't
really know why and it's often a very
personal story or there's a personal
journey that takes you there I think for
our five core founders they they always
just struck me as being very they care a
lot about people mm-hmm they're really
people people people they cared a lot
about China but but you have to remember
like in 1990s China's very poor and in
China was it didn't have a lot of people
are trying to deny they have a lot of
confidence that they could even build a
good company or that the company could
even have an international presence I
spent quite a few years like trying to
unpack some of those ideas because I
felt they were false but you know China
came in to the world having been totally
cut off till 1978
then like gradually kind of opening up
and and kind of trying to figure out
what's been going on outside of China
yeah for all these years and now it
seems crazy talking about that but
that's really where the world was like
20 years yeah okay so I think you know
our founders really we're always very
interested to spend time with the users
online like on the bulletin boards
responding to users directly responding
in chat rooms or making friends I mean
they were power users of QQ themselves
some of them might even be guilty of
being power daters in there like they're
just meeting people and they're like
they're making the service for that
they're just as much users of the
service as other people are and they're
inherently curious about people and very
good nature so I think what happened to
the company is it started with an idea
but it quickly became successful and we
got a lot of traffic and the way our
founding team in executive committee
responded to that was by actually
feeling like a sense of responsibility
for the users and and a deep curiosity
to figure it out like what more could we
do and what do these people really want
and back in China you know you're just
actually triggering a memory right now
China had a lot of fundamental needs
then that are maybe surprising to people
now because in like the late 1990s early
2000s there was almost no investment in
private media in China so all television
all film most all the magazines
certainly all the newspapers I think
even to this day most of them you know
were state funded so you have this big
gap with respect to like just private
media yeah you know by everyday people
and there are so many services it was
clear that people needed back then just
because they're human beings they want
to laugh they want to tell dirty jokes
they want to date you know they want to
play games um we were filling in this
gap and I think you know as a class of
companies the Internet companies in
China this is the role we've played
we've really led the role of bringing
private capital and entrepreneurship to
media and connections and services for
consumers in China but it really filled
a vacuum well there was nothing there
before and I think that was very much in
the minds of our founders that this the
required this entailed a lot of
responsibility if you're going to manage
all these users so um so maybe to tie it
back to the local point you said so how
did they figure out what the local needs
were right diversified so okay like the
methodology right and and I love
answering that question because it's
pretty simple one basically from a
pretty early point on we we knew that
it's essential to understand our users
as deeply as possible and we should use
basically any methodology that we can
learn about to deepen that understanding
and we didn't settle on any preference
for any kind of methodology because each
situation seems to need its own
methodology but we got very fascinated
by what we were learning about what was
happening overseas I remember I did a
specific trip probably 2005 or 2006 to
learn about things that like into it was
doing called like follow me home mm-hmm
like how do you how do you how do you
kind of go crazy with respect to like
really getting into users heads and I
thought that's that's a really cool idea
I can just remember that example very
specifically so we wanted to learn from
Intuit and others like how do you do a
follow me home session like how do you
actually work with someone and if you've
heard about that but like you can go
into their house and you can see I want
you I want to watch you using Internet
services in your home right pretty much
what I want to see your home and I want
to see like how it fits in to your life
and maybe you're having an argument with
a spouse on the side or some kids just
got home and the TV's on and where's the
computer sitting is in the kitchen is in
the bedroom is it and why did you put it
in the bedroom you don't have space is
that it or like you know what's we
wanted to get into the the deepest
possible narrative behind the users use
of our service we wanted to understand
their entire lives their their broader
needs like and at the most fundamental
level and then how internet services
were playing into those needs and and we
started having very difficult
conversations with ourself some base if
I skip forward a little bit a few years
down the road we built something called
avatars and the advertiser service would
grow for a while then it would kind of
like recede and have high turn rates and
we're kind of wondering why and and I
think it was very important for us to
ask these deeper questions like why do
people really like avatars because you
could have a service that's working
earning revenue and maybe getting a lot
of recognition but even the product
director the other person who came up
with a product themselves they weren't
really very clear why people liked it
they didn't ask deep questions they kind
of got lucky get it out there people
liked it and you kind of did new things
and some things work some things didn't
but we started going to a more
fundamental level really in the mid
2000s I think we always had the thinking
going early on yeah but we just I think
we've been getting better and better at
these like they're kind of deeper almost
existential questions like like when you
say people like avatars because well
they want to look better online they're
like well why do they want to look
better online because they're meeting
other people why do they care about
meeting other people you know because
they want to make friends why do they
want to make friends you know you just
keep going down down down like the users
yeah I'm their desire yeah waiting maybe
they're lonely
ultimately or they say they want
affirmation they you know everyone wants
to feel appreciated and and so if you
came to that kind of conclusion if that
was like they concluded mysteries like
everyone's feel appreciate would say
okay interesting how can we deliver a
sense of appreciation to our users
through our product yeah like how can
how can that be how can those values
somehow be captured through the user
interfaces and and the structure of the
product and maybe we don't even get that
right and maybe we were wrong about some
of our conclusions but we're constantly
like trying to iterate at that so what
was the next big thing that came after
mobile get you yeah thank you so we did
some of these services I remember
avatars probably came out around 2003 we
built our portal in around 2003 what we
were trying to do let me explain it yeah
I'll get to the the specifics but at a
strategic level we wanted to offer I
thought about it in my mind anyways as
like a spider web type configuration of
value here's what it is you have QQ at
the center then you have like mobile QQ
here you have premium QQ here now if we
can add something else let's say it's
like music the question is how can music
not only add value between users and QQ
but also add value to mobile QQ have a
premium QQ offering like okay if it's
premium QQ then maybe there's a new
album that's gonna come out yeah next
week the only premium Kubica users can
can listen to for like two weeks
something like that and we constantly
like find an opportunity and then how
can the music service not just be about
streaming music but maybe the ringtones
inside
q like when you send some in a message
the notification could could use the
music service it's like give us any kind
of resource and we'll try to find like
the most efficient way to like
distribute it intelligently in different
kinds of iterations and ways throughout
the network and then you add something
else you have a fourth service and if it
service and then you're going back to
the other ones and you're trying to like
see how they're all going to strengthen
each other like it's a connected network
you know drive out the value of all
users yeah I mean that's what we did as
a company between users is that you see
how users are connected and each one
might have 150 friends and then you get
these like amazing relationship grids
between friends but we also kind of felt
that way about the services and the
value themselves I guess it's just
habitual thinking because we're always
thinking in that mode you add something
new into the network and how can it like
basically from a business perspective
values try to connect to all the other
aspects of the service and what I found
we did over time is we started to build
like these really intricate webs of
product experiences that like our
competitors just weren't doing and and
it's hard to replicate and and we
thought this would be a very valuable to
differentiate us from other typical
instant messaging companies the more
kind of value-added services we had
around QQ and the more complex ways we
could integrate them for user value we
felt like that would be very defendable
and be very unique versus like other
services where they might bring in music
but like when another service brought in
music they might say click this button
and stream the music yeah okay that's
cool kind of sounds like iTunes but yeah
like how could you make that more
interesting and and we would be
challenging ourselves to do it and
working with those product managers like
in the music team to make sure they had
that mentality that they were kind of
pushing the boundaries to say how can i
maybe work with another product I've got
it and and and we're the executive team
would often get involved because we have
to do something other than just the
general managers like yeah what
executive is like we're looking out for
those opportunities when are there
disagreements when is it that one team
really wants another team to work with
them but the other team isn't willing to
because of deadlines or they don't like
the idea our goal would be like saying
what do like reduce the friction and
come to quicker decisions like okay you
guys really should be working together
we've heard the arguments work together
kind of a thing or yeah this doesn't
make sense like okay we totally get it
yeah back down you know like kind of how
do you decide when to accelerate a
certain kind of integration or to you
know to just let it go and then we have
some sometimes some okay ideas ourselves
we like oh we want the company to do
this sorry everyone do this thing but
really kind of driving that that
strategic integration between products
that was the this is something that we
established I think very early on like
2002 2003 we kind of really started
driving these integrations when we did
our portal I remember shortly after we
have a like a CNN com tech news portal
we started doing these I thought were
fantastic news updates in QQ so when a
major global event happened you would
just get a pop up on your desk from QQ
and that was another great example of
the integration that happened fairly
shortly after and now I see it in like
iPhone you get these like yeah that's
like oh 10 remind me what we did like
back in 2003 with QQ yeah Oh 13 years
earlier but I think that's very unique
that you mentioned which is it was not
just about building different products
and even though it looks for the outside
world that you know Tencent does you
know has a lot of things it's about that
real integration across each of these
products and services that increases the
value it's like an ecosystem of value
yeah and it's like the question would be
how can music fundamentally like like
transform the whole QQ experience top to
bottom and other value-added services
that we have like like the premium
service remember that exactly I said ok
there's new releases coming up maybe
there's a concert coming in town but
because we work with the music label we
can inform them of the concert and and
and then also that premium group can be
a helpful group for the yeah the music
labels to work with you in some cases so
we're like constantly kind of trying to
drive these webs of value in all these
different ways and and it becomes a
thought process in an operating system
for the company and I think we've become
pretty good at it and it led us like
scale let's go and then so now if I just
fast-forward to WeChat yeah it's really
hard for people outside of China
sometimes to understand WeChat first of
all it's in Chinese I understand but
it's also a pretty complex product
there's a lot of different things
happening in there fortunately I had a
quest
before you jumped into a vagina you
started off as a I am service thank you
and mobile and premium so why acquire
WeChat
oh well know we chat was developed
internally oh that's quite fun company I
think they found 2005 and he joined us
and he worked on mail for many many
years and then he had the idea for
WeChat I recall it being around 2010
yeah and he went for it and it was
pretty successful right out of the gate
and we really wanted to foster a mobile
first I am service even a QQ was very
successful on mobile it funded me as a
mobile services yeah but it we had been
doing mobile since I think late 2000
yeah and we had always built mobile QQ
for all the different operating systems
like Symbian or Java or whatever is
going to be but we felt like it was
things were pivoting so much too mobile
that we also had to have a mobile first
messenger while still embracing QQ & QQ
still has yeah a very healthy audience
today and that is something very unique
to Tencent because you know he had Yahoo
Messenger we had AOL yeah but actually
none of the PC messengers went to mobile
first here but you know Tenzin was the
first to do that yeah for us we had to
it was the only way we could think of
making money at scale back then and our
users demanded it they wanted they were
on the move they wanted to be able to
text back and forth and so so we did
that but the WeChat point we can talk
about we chat more but I feel like just
in a nutshell it's kind of like like as
an executive team and as a company we
learned so much from building QQ over
the years when we got to WeChat it was a
new platform but also you know had some
great organic growth and all this really
important core interaction around it
when it came time to building
value-added services around WeChat it
just came to us very naturally because
we had learned so much over like you
know over a decade you know probably
like 12 years of learning by the time we
got to WeChat and and we had also
matured as people too before we were
very focused on games and more like
avatar like cute services and WeChat has
plenty of that too but we also started
thinking more about the economy more
about financial services about
e-commerce about how do you really
transform a business or
hospital or government using WeChat and
I think we we had so much experience
with platform services and and tying
services together in a seamless way that
when it came time to WeChat it was like
okay good fresh platform let's get
everything right this time or let's do
some things that we couldn't pull off
the last time around in QQ I feel like
that was part of the thought process do
you want me to talk a little bit about
gaming I think game yeah I was wondering
how did Vincent do I do gaming because
part of this story the message yeah yeah
yeah and I think it's a it's a really
good example for people to yeah to think
about for us because the thing I love
about the gaming case is that the first
four years of our gaming attempts were
characterized by utter failure and why
did you decide to do gaming yeah so
around 2003 what we call massive
multiplayer online games started
becoming very popular in China have you
ever played World of Warcraft before oh
you have heard about that you've heard
about it but you know you get you get
kind of really deep into this experience
yeah it's got a big software client you
say a couple gigabytes that you download
and then it's kind of this whole world
right and these were becoming these kind
of games were becoming very popular in
China and we started thinking it is
possible that users like to interact
with each other so much in these worlds
that they're not going to want to
interact via QQ anymore this could be
potentially like an existential threat
to us QQ was really text driven at the
time most of the interaction was a text
there was some voice some video you
could do video instant messaging things
like that but it's Bromley text and and
therefore it's pretty black and white
you would go into these worlds and you
can feel like you're really deeply
interacting with someone so we felt like
this is an existential threat for the
company we have to find ways to
integrate QQ more with games or else we
could just be like out of the picture
right so I think that was before we had
the idea that this could possibly make
money it was more like if we don't do it
our users might just go into all these
games and they're like why do I didn't
want to talk to someone in QQ and I can
be dressed up as an avatar and I can
have like a deep rich environmental
experience you know it's a software
environment
so we started trying to license games
and build games ourselves and pretty
much everything we did for the first
three or four years were spectacular
failures I thought we were gonna save
are spectacular but no failure well I
mean whether or not we like what we did
it doesn't really matter because the
users didn't so that's all that we can
hear about yeah that's a very important
thing for Tencent I think we can pivot
fast as a company because especially we
win to the gaming area there's a lot of
artists and designers and games and they
have something that they want to do they
want it to look a certain way they want
to have people experience a design a
certain way and that's like their goal
and for us we've always been like we
want to find what users love we want to
find a gaming experience that they love
so if the colors need to change if the
artwork needs to change if the design
needs to change great like users will
show you a bunch of options we'll test
those options but show us the way and
and that's that's kind of in the gaming
world it's a bit of a different
philosophy than some others that like
kind of have a top-down beautiful vision
for an experience and then they have to
realize it we were always like very
practical like oh that doesn't work
let's pivot it like no worries about it
so but you did enjoy gaming for four
years yeah well so what did work was our
casual gaming experience that's like you
know really simple card games and things
like that and we were we found quickly
that that was a very nice complement to
QQ because he'd be talking we'd be
chatting on QQ what's up yeah nothing
much hey let's go play a little pool you
know let's go play some whatever
blackjack okay you know now now we know
we found something more fun to do
because typically we just be texting but
then it's like hey I haven't seen you
for a while let's do something else in
here you know it gave like the users
kind of like a playground and added a
depth to the interaction but for a long
time that was the only thing we could
claim that was working and and I have
this I was very involved with our gaming
strategy particularly on the
international front so there's nothing
more exciting than going to like a
gaming company in the US and saying hey
we'd love for you to come to China would
you like to work with us and I'm saying
like no like like there's not gonna be
any market there it's clear like how
BIG's your market and we'd be like well
we think it's gonna be big we're not too
sure yet exactly how fast it'll take but
let's figure that together and they'd be
like yeah I don't think so
I was I was
I was kind of I had a frustrating period
as a professional for a while trying to
find any Western companies to work with
us I love saying that because the morale
the story is were the largest gaming
company in the world for quite some time
now
it has been at least five years yeah
position so it's kind of like wow how
quickly the world can change right
nothing new to Silicon Valley but you
know at that time I live through yeah
yeah so what happened well we had all
these kind of licenses that didn't go so
great games we built they didn't go so
great but we signed a game called
crossfire it's a first-person shooter
game okay you know like shooting yeah
yeah okay and it just took off mmm and
when it took off it started making a lot
of money and that's all most people need
to see like they don't wanna hear your
argument they want to hear philosophy
the whole reason why q.q is amazing and
China is amazing they just want to show
me the money and yeah it just took off
and then we signed up another game
called dungeon fighter and that took off
- it did really well and I think with
those two games those were both licensed
from Korea by the water with those two
games it became clear like okay 10 cents
a player we hadn't really become a
leader yet we became maybe like number
four number five in the gaming industry
but it was clear there's something going
on never really games yeah and then
these games just kept growing they're
still they're still very popular game
yeah and these are probably over ten
years old yeah in the market they're
still doing very well that's what's
really phenomenal about ten cent you are
at the core of it now people recognize
it as a gaming company yet you have this
amazing product called WeChat which has
actually got a lot of international
attention yeah over recent years and QQ
is still strong and you have this
integration of services yeah that just
increases I have value to the user so I
think it's very unique to see a company
that was founded in 2000 or 2001 to
constantly evolve yeah as trends have
changed that's what we do
yeah we still embrace the old stuff like
QQ is still operating yes that's really
hundreds of millions may have many
hundreds of millions of users it's not
it's a little smaller than we check now
I believe but it's not that much smaller
smaller but not a smaller because we jet
itself is 890 mah so yeah
a little more now okay the last time I
checked let's do it yeah you know so
yeah so we managed to and we keep keep
moving on and I think we we have I can't
even explain some time we do have this
interesting ability to like scale
quickly like when we see a few games
that are working we can build a model
for how we forecast the performance of
the game how we license the game the
templates all that the contracts and
things like that and then we can just
like replicate it really quickly
yeah because once our games became
profitable so ok great let's invest in
great game licenses from around the
world and then it's just about the
pipeline and the amazing thing about the
China market especially with respect to
games if I think about very specifically
is that there's a lot of users there and
a lot of users mean there's a lot of
different needs you're gay yeah and and
we haven't found a situation yet where
it feels like all the needs have been
met even though there's big successful
franchises and new things coming out all
the time there's always there's always a
nice yeah there's another 5 million or
10 million a group of 5 to 10 million
people don't want a certain kind of
experience that when you deliver it to
them yeah there's a good business there
so switching gears a little bit you know
your current title is the chief
exploration yes sorry what does the
chief exploration officer do it's a good
question I wanted a title so I've been
with the company for a long time I
wanted a title that deliberately is
always gonna make sense no matter what
I'm doing and it can suit my needs
whenever it was I wanted it to be
serious but at the same time I just
wanted it to be like kind of a crazy
title deliberately and it actually
started because I said I want to be
called to see something we had this
discussion a few years ago I was always
senior executive vice president I
thought it's like like no one thinks I'm
like a c-level guy this is really
frustrating I don't care about titles at
all but I found other people cared even
inside the company they cared like I was
always puzzled by that so I kind of
liked about two or three years ago I
said okay just give me some kind of C
title I said well what should that be
she'd be like CX something that's it
that's it see the X the X is cool like
people like the X I think it's cool yeah
exploration which is what I've always
tried to do so I've really always wanted
my role in
to be going back to those days when I
left chin Jen right after our
transaction with ten cent and I became
part of the executive team and I said it
okay I'm moving to Silicon Valley
we're only forty five people we have 46
people now one of them's in Silicon
Valley like we're gonna be a global
company mm-hmm and we're gonna be a
global company because we're gonna be
part of Silicon Valley we're gonna be
working with all our peers here we're
gonna be exposed to technology trends
we're gonna be contributing we are a
global company from the early days and
that was not in people's minds for
Ashenden based company in 2001 like not
even sure if they're gonna survive or
not not even sure if they could handle
the China market and you know like
feeling a little outgunned by the
Beijing and Shanghai players because you
know Shenzhen didn't have a lot of
technology it's like to say like we're
gonna be internationally it was it was
kind of a new idea it was a new idea at
the time
yeah so I've always tried to just what I
considered you do which is like pushing
the frontier $0.10 in anyway like just I
always won like shake things up over
there now there got a point 17 years now
I've been with the company about four or
five years ago one thing we talked about
in $0.10 is we want to use technology to
improve people's lives we want to use
the internet to improve people's lives
and hopefully we're doing some of that
with everything we do I personally
always felt a little bit like there's a
lot more we can do like I think we've in
some ways we've kind of become very
adept at understanding people's
emotional needs what the brain needs
information entertainment games
education all that you know music art
all that kind of stuff I think we're we
lead in those spaces in China but I was
always kind of thinking about our
mission and like looking at the entire
human being right and when you start
thinking about the human being a couple
ideas really started to resonate with me
and I couldn't get them out of my head
one is that you know I want to see
people living healthier lives how can
technology help everyday individuals
live healthier lives I just felt like
there's so much happening with
technology they can contribute to that
and if we did it as a company even if
like I'm kind of driving some of the
stuff on the cutting edge we can't be
wrong even if we get it wrong we can say
we tried and I think that's good for our
users it's good for our employees it's a
good use of
or some aspect of our profits right you
know so it's always the right battle to
be fighting right so I felt even though
it's risky like I can I can just push
this forward and like just everyone
better get out of my way kind of a thing
the other thing is when you think about
an individual though and you want to
have them live healthier lives you can
understand like their body their blood
do they have cancer all those kind of
things but then you also have to think
about the ecosystem that the individual
living in and and you know if you think
about cancer for example you have to be
very sensitive to like a thoughtful
about environmental circumstances air
pollution water contaminants and water
food I mean what are the causes of
cancer there's so many of them that are
traced to be like somehow environmental
in nature so I started thinking more
about ecosystem impacts on the
individual and and that's how I kind of
really started thinking about this title
in this role and and kind of trying to
encourage the company to go in like a
very new direction which is really
thinking about how can we use technology
to create a more resilient planet
I call it planetary resilience it's a
bit of a mouthful I want to find a
better way to describe this quickly to
people it should be something that
everyone's talking about now so when I
just started with these baseline
concerns based on things that I knew at
the time what when I started doing more
systematically with a small team that I
have I have what's called an exploration
team basically it's about five people
yeah I like I believe small is beautiful
yeah and we have a lot of people ten set
that can support us with any specific
initiative but at least for myself and
like working with a team every day for
me it has to be like maybe no more than
eight or something like that we kind of
thought will be like B C's mm-hmm okay
and VC's look for great entrepreneurs
and great technologies and great
products in traction right
I thought we want to do that too we love
that discipline it's something that we
feel like we know pretty well and we can
do a good job at always can improve but
but I thought we should do it with a
twist we spend about half our time
roughly speaking thinking about the
problems in the world okay that might be
a little different and not really
thinking about markets
different than saying where the markets
you know where's the next movie ticket
you can sell it or something like that
I'm talking about problems like we try
to forecast what are the biggest
challenges the world is going to face in
the coming years as like a strategic
trajectory and and then you'll start
looking at factors when you ask those
questions
baseline factors like what does
population growth look like on earth
human beings when I bet invested in
$0.10 in 2000 2001 the planet had 6
point 1 billion people was a different
planet then now we're at 7.4 7.5 roughly
so in just that period of time
yeah and then the forecasts which looks
pretty likely to be realized will be to
add another billion people in 13 years
so if you can just track it and
understand these types of fundamental
trajectories it gives you a lot of power
to forecast the future
because you know all these humans we're
all going to need to eat yeah and we
need some fresh water we like when our
air is clean we need to get around we
need energy right and we want to
actually distribute these benefits to
all even if in an undistributed world
there's gonna be a lot of demands for
these resources let alone improving the
world right so when you start thinking
that's what we really do as as the CXO
as a chief exploration officer in our
team we spend a lot of time thinking
about problems on one side then on the
other side we're kind of acting like a
VC but with a little bit of a twist so
we're interested in all the latest
trends and we think what Tencent is
well-suited to do is work in kind of
with new technologies mm-hmm things like
artificial intelligence new types of
sensors like satellites or you know so
many kind of sensors coming out now
genetic engineering advances and like
energy or transportation so we're
interested in all those things but we
want to see those technology when our
team works on these things we want to
see those technologies being applied to
the world's biggest challenges so it's
taking this in all these kind of new
directions which makes every day very
exciting we started just thinking about
agriculture maybe a year or two ago and
not really knowing anything about
agriculture but just like when you learn
about the problems and the stresses on a
planetary scale let alone local scale
you know for agriculture it's just
completely amazing and then you discover
that the agriculture industry is is
fairly antiquated you know and there's a
lot of
and that that suggests that like world
agriculture food security is going to
get more difficult over time whether
it's like problems with fertilizer
topsoil erosion water scarcity like just
loss of land arable land and things like
this I mean you can just go on and on
right yeah the world's addiction to meat
I can go on I get a little political
about it right like like and so and so
so we'll start with a problem and then
we'll look for companies that we think
are going to tackle that thesis and we
might meet with like dozens you know
hundreds of companies that don't really
do it for us or you know we'll meet with
a lot of companies and then finally you
know we hope we can find as many as
possible but finally we'll find a few
that that can work out and then we just
want to keep building on our experience
and what we've learned and and what
we're continue to learn in these areas
so so it's an area where I think by
focusing on the problems were we're very
willing to go into like some like an
area like agriculture where we knew
nothing about it
and we're kind of applying these skills
I feel like at least myself I was
applying the same skills when we were
trying to get into gaming in 2003 so I
think I left this out of the story about
gaming but we started in gaming we were
complete nobodies yeah like we didn't
know what questions to ask we didn't
know how a game was built yeah I didn't
know that you had to have art or
designers and I thought this is really
cool like like I'm kind of artistic
pushed myself I get to work with artists
now in the gaming uh well there was like
I don't even think about that when we
started getting into games and and it's
amazing that with a lot of determination
you can learn a lot in a short amount of
time maybe like to get to 50% it can be
pretty quick and then like getting the
last 50% is why you have to have so much
mass in artistry and like going to
school and whatever you have to do but
like getting up to speed like half the
way you know for a lot of areas can be
pretty quickly if you just want to do it
and I think this is a really important
skill set that Tencent has across the
board is that we've been down this road
so many times like going into new
business areas yeah like gaming and the
types of game that when we do the next
one like a lot of the management in the
company a lot of our executives they
have experience doing the exact same
things so we kind of all share this
operating system like oh you're gonna go
from now like okay what are the key
questions to ask and you know economics
and
all the and I'm not saying it takes time
to get good at it but at least in terms
of a willingness in a culture of being
like excited and curious to get up to
speed on a lot of issues quickly I think
we have that in the company so
everyone's very supportive and it takes
you know they're almost like you know
that has been the theme of Tencent it is
not known as one company it is acrimony
which does you know really good things
in many areas and now here you are you
have an exploration team yes
trying to solve you know real big
problems yeah so I would say life and
what I want to do in ten cent with this
position is is say people intended start
things yeah like we should be doing
stuff in agriculture we've got our cloud
we've got all these using WeChat so many
farmers are using WeChat like why don't
we do that early I want to be catalyzing
those moments and finding those
opportunities were these things that
seem to be far off actually can rather
quickly kind of merge into the broader
ecosystem and become part of the
ecosystem but the intention of why we're
doing is very important we're not just
seeking profits although I think
agriculture is very profitable yeah if
you're playing in it in the right way
that's why everyone's getting fat yeah
the most part at least yeah from the
most part right so so that's really the
idea there and what we're doing this so
we act as a VC we have about roughly 70
companies that I'm in my team are
managing directly we have more that we
kind of manage with other teams and then
we also have other Tencent teams doing
investments in other areas sometimes
also in these kind of resilience related
areas I tend to think my team is driving
most of it but I love it when other
teams in $0.10 also do these investments
especially in China and so yeah there's
quite a few teams at tents of doing
investing by the way it's not just only
my team yeah we have what we call the
M&A team there also that's just the name
yeah from the past they're also doing
investments so there's you might a
company could get contacted by one of
many different investment teams at $0.10
and that's also kind of part of the
philosophy of the company that we want
to be very market driven yeah we want to
make sure that we have multiple teams
approaching multiple strategies in an
area like we have QQ and WeChat and we
have multiple teams doing investments
yeah if it reasons and and a different
team might look at it from a different
perspective and
and either get excited to be less
excited but in a way it's it's a it's it
allows our executive team to have a lot
of different strategies in play in the
market yeah and that way we kind of have
a lot of option a letís at all together
yeah and what is actually gonna happen
yeah going forward
thank you so much David thanks for
having us for the Q&A and yeah really
appreciate you appreciate you speaking
of having me today thank you
you